nombreux pays livre des denrées
alimentaires et du matériel au peuple
afghan c'est notamment le cas de la
russie qui multiplie les rotations à
l'aéroport de kaboul un reportage signé
antoyé antoine clermont notre envoyé
spécial sur place
la communauté internationale commence
doucement réagir face à la catastrophe
humanitaire qui se profile en
afghanistan lors d'une rencontre entre
américain est taliban à doigts la
délégation américaine a fait savoir
qu'elle s'engager à soutenir les efforts
de l'onu pour faire face à la situation
la banque mondiale qui a suspendu ses
aides à kaboul au mois d'août dernier
envisage de nouveau à fournir de l'aide
humanitaire en afghanistan en attendant
la russie aj et vient de livrer une
deuxième cargaison d'aidé humanitaire en
moins de deux semaines
en application de la directive du
président russe le ministère de la
défense a envoyé le 1er décembre une
nouvelle cargaison d'aidé humanitaire au
peuple afghan
l'aviation militaire de transport des
forces aérospatiale russe a transporté à
kaboul 36 tonnes de denrées alimentaires
une autre cargaison à attend son tour le
volume général des livraisons
humanitaires dépassera les 100 tonnes il
faut dire que la situation sociale et
économique
ici en afghanistan est très mauvaise ce
tiers du chômage de la famille de la
misère tout l'hiver s'accrochera et pire
ça deviendra
la situation humanitaire empire de jour
en jour en afghanistan l'économie est
paralysée le système de santé est aux
abois et sans une aide massive de la
part de la communauté internationale le
pays court à la catastrophe